so we sort of got
into this place where we can make
anything we want
all the way at the scale of the atom
while at the same time we need that more
than ever
to solve the most pressing global
challenges it's a really exciting time
to understand
how atoms come together and what we can
do with that
today on shock radio we're talking atoms
in this episode we're going to see what
it takes to bring concepts from
theory to reality and how one professor
at mit
has learned to make his course content
real tangible
and important to his students if you can
touch and feel some aspect of what
you're learning
then you learn it in a richer way right
you learn it from a different
angle you you see the problem a little
bit differently
we're going to explore the world of
solid state chemistry
course 3091 which as always is available
on
mit open courseware and to take us
through
we're talking with professor jeffrey
grossman
i am the head of the department of
materials science and engineering at mit
i teach 3091 and i do it as the lead
instructor
but it's only possible to teach it
effectively because i have an
outstanding staff
of tas as well as a wonderful course
administrator
who all come together and we give it our
all
you know every fall so that's why the
course works
and this course like many others we've
highlighted on our show
needs a team that understands how to
speak and appeal to a general audience
an audience that may not know much about
chemistry to begin with
this course is what we at mit call a gir
or general institute requirement
before a student can graduate from mit
with an undergraduate degree they have
to have taken one semester of chemistry
so we emphasize uh the basic building
blocks of chemistry and then we build
solids
out of those and so so the basic
building blocks are atoms and the way
atoms bond together
and then how those atoms come together
to make solid materials and that's why
the
the course that i teach is called solid
state chemistry
you've probably heard of the stone age
and the iron age
but what age are we living in now part
of what makes this course so interesting
and one of the reasons that i wanted to
share it with you is that it invites you
to explore
questions just like this questions that
take a contemporary look
at solid-state chemistry so as a
material scientist
and engineer i love the fact that
we tend to name the age we live in
by the sort of material that mattered
most
in that age i would say that recently
we've had the age of
silicon the age of plastics right
i think that we have reached a time
in science and engineering where
we will never be able to do that again
i.e
to name the age we live in by some
single material and the reason is that
we are now at a place where we can
actually
design any material any way we want all
the way down
to the atoms that make it up and so
that's a kind of new era
and i call that the age of materials
design it's really the age of atomic
scale materials design there's a very
famous speech that richard feynman gave
called um there's plenty of room at the
bottom
and it was really sort of the first
vision of what what would happen if you
could sort of move atoms around
anywhere you wanted right and and well
you could make pretty much
anything right and and so the the
question then is
um how could you do that and then the
other question is what would you make
and if that wasn't enough to pique your
interest professor grossman makes sure
to apply these questions to the issues
that affect
humanity on a global scale
what is so exciting about the fact that
we now are able to put atoms anywhere we
want
that has come at a critical moment in
the challenge that
that we face globally in energy
in climate and sustainability and many
other challenges
because at the heart of getting through
and
solving these really hard problems lies
the design of a new material
and so so we sort of got into this place
where we can make anything we want all
the way at the scale of the atom
and while at the same time we need that
more than ever to solve the most
pressing global challenges
it's a really exciting time to
understand how atoms come together and
what we can do with that
[Music]
to professor grossman the real world
applications of solid state chemistry
are just as important as the theoretical
concepts
so much so in fact that every single
lecture has an added element that
explains how students can practically
apply the concepts in the real world
just because i'm teaching say a lecture
on the periodic table
or i'm teaching a lecture on lewis
structures
or i'm teaching a lecture on x-ray
generation
it doesn't mean i can't connect in each
case
to some sort of bigger picture question
or or something that they can really
connect to
that is more broadly sort of accessible
i call it my why this matters moment
because it gives
context and i think we as
as teachers should be able to do that
with anything we're teaching
so for every single one of the 36
lectures that i teach
i take a while this matters moment and i
connect
what it is that we learned right there
in that lecture
to some sort of pressing global
challenge or maybe it's a technology
that they all know
or can connect to just to give that
context
and as you may have guessed the why this
matters moments
are a favorite part of professor
grossman's lectures and
not just for the students it's also
really important for me
because it makes me excited and it makes
me
every year come up with sort of new
ideas for how to relate the material to
some
you know bigger picture aspect of their
lives
in the first year i actually wound up
sometimes
cutting that short you know sometimes i
had too much material to get through in
a lecture and so
we didn't get to the why this matters
and what i heard from students
was how that was such a an important
part of each lecture that they didn't
want me to ever cut it short and so i've
been very protective
of those moments of class because as
soon as i
put the why this matters moment in front
of them they sit at the edge of their
seats
i feel that this is something that we
could do
in any class we teach i don't care if
it's some advanced algebra or python
programming class or
civil engineering it doesn't matter
every time we teach
i think that we can take what we're
teaching and we can try
to give it some sort of of context
how what they've just learned connects
to something else
at the heart of professor grossman's
teaching is a focus on allowing his
students to see
and touch and interact with the subject
matter to make it apparent to the senses
in order to make it matter i always feel
that if you can
sort of touch and feel
some aspect of what you're learning then
you learn it
in a richer way right you learn it from
a different
angle you you see the problem a little
bit differently
so in the very first lecture in fact in
the introductory lecture i talk about
how
it is that chemistry came to be what was
sort of the early goals
of chemists what were they trying to do
and one of the things that they did
is they took things like a rock right
and say well
how do you break this down what's it
made of and so they smash it or they
light stuff on fire we don't tell them
we don't tell our students to do that by
the way
or they they they mix things together
right so they smash it they
break it they'd mix it with that they'd
mix it with that right and they say well
what happens
and through that came discovery of the
basic building blocks of matter
and so what i wanted is i wanted to say
well okay let's put ourselves
back in that position at the time my
youngest daughter was six
and so you know she had had something
like three birthday parties she went to
in one weekend
and so our hallway had a whole bunch of
these goodie bags
with like candy and disney toys
and i was looking at those things you
know maybe we could put chemistry in
these bags
so we created a set of goodie bags about
one each week
and so in the very first goodie bag i
give students
five different strips of of something
i don't tell them what they are and i
give them a ruler
to measure the strips um they can weigh
them
and i give them some vinegar and again
the idea is to
try to put them in the position of well
let me give you things that you don't
know what they are how would you figure
that out
and that gets to a really important part
of the goodie bag it is meant to
complement what i'm teaching by giving
like
a way for them to touch and hold and
interact with the chemistry but it's
also meant
for them if they want to go beyond what
we're learning
and to try their own ideas out
professor grossman knows his methods
aren't exactly conventional
and might not even be effective in every
given scenario
but his teaching experiments are guided
by strong communication with his
students
and a simple yet powerful philosophy
trust the process you don't have to
have everything worked perfectly but
work on it together with your students
and you know so the goodie bags i was
very excited about them but i think they
really needed to be tried
for a year and then to figure out sort
of well okay what worked and what didn't
work
and and let me get feedback and let me
talk to students about it
and then let's let's make them better
and i think that's true every year
i always want to teach better and i
always want to
get feedback and realize what doesn't
work
and what does and then amplify what does
and add to it
and trying new ideas out is a part of
that process
i tell my students all the time that
success
this is so important right progress has
nothing
at all to do with success nothing
progress has
to do with what we choose to do with
failure
you know because that is then what leads
to to the success
and i try to convey that to students and
i have to convey it to myself
as well right that you have to remind
ourselves that we're all in that same
position
and so professor grossman continues to
work on inspiring his students to
explore new ways of looking at the world
one goody bag at a time he's made all of
his teaching materials from introduction
to solid state chemistry
openly available to you on our mit open
courseware website
so be sure to check them out
thank you for listening we hope you're
feeling as excited as we are
to keep learning we'd love to hear how
you use the resources on mit open
courseware to power change in your life
classroom or community you can send us
an email or even call us to tell us your
story
and we'll share it with other listeners
so they can feel inspired too
our phone number is 617-475-0534
and you can also find it in the show
notes signing off from cambridge
massachusetts
i'm sarah hansen from mit open
courseware
mom pass the card